[Music]
we're sailing towards an iceberg little
white peak in the distance getting
closer and closer but really it's been
underneath us the whole time it's
nothing worse than a kid we have some
bad news on the case the print we lifted
from the victim is from your son there's
got to be an explanation they go to the
same school Jacobs in his class yes we
know that Lina have you arrested my son
before we begin I want to make something
clear a kid your age charged with
first-degree murder
is tried as an adult I swear I didn't
tell me
we believe you you have admitted to
being in the park and a fellow student
alleges you had a knife she would bring
to school I guess if saying he looks
smug and remorseless this is gonna
follow him around for the rest of his
life it's a mistake I'm gonna figure it
out
chip any doubts about Jacobs in us no of
course not
where is the knife now
so you've been lying to me I did what
any parent would have done can lead his
fader to the courtroom
my only job now is trying to protect our
son recruiters in our own home
acting like verdoorn we are norm oh my
god do you think this is normal
you gotta get answers for ourselves I
know what you did
lawyers have boundaries I don't anymore
remember that in their eyes it isn't
just Jacob who's guilty
you all are did you follow me here he's
damaging this is evidence you're scaring
him good he should be scared I'm scared
so I have to know
I want the truth
you can be a good man or you can be a
good father it was no normal to go back
- it was just before and after
you
you